foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the story and maybe you got a
chance to follow this but uh there was a
fishing tournament that was in uh upper
Ohio here and uh it was the Lake Erie
walleye tournament called loot l-e-w-t
Lake Erie walleye Trail and uh the
winners were disqualified because they
found weights in the fish that they
caught and there's a lot of money at
stake here the winning prize was close
to 29 000 but these guys have been
winning this is a a season-long event
they start in the summer and it wraps up
uh this past Friday and you may have
seen the video and uh it went viral as
the kids like to say they cut open the
fish and you saw the weights fall out
so
so it became a big deal that they're
cheating in fishing and these guys have
won close to three hundred thousand
dollars
these these guys are like the Lance
Armstrong of uh fishing here they're
Barry Bonds
McGuire and Sosa
but uh Matt Markey covers the event
covered the event he's the outdoors
editor for uh the Toledo Blade and he
joins us on the program Matt thanks for
joining us explain the tournament for
our audience
this particular tournament was the
championship for that Lake Erie walleye
Trail circuit and it involved
um probably 30 or 40 two-person teams
and the top prize would have been with
bonuses and all maybe 30 to 40 000 but
there's a lot of uh other tournaments
including two major tournaments that
take place from the middle of October
till the weekend after Thanksgiving and
in those both of those have more than
400 000 in total prize money with
125 150 000 going to the winner so the
the stakes are a lot higher than than
most people would think when it comes to
walleye fishing when did we know that
there was uh something up
we knew I've been hearing it for about a
year with this particular pair behind
the scenes guys Whispering you know
complaining and all but nobody willing
to make a formal complaint or to charge
them you know in the Public Square but
there have been a lot of rumors in it
most of them involved this particular
pair but once this tournament uh the
first day was held you come in there's a
way in there's some Pomp and
Circumstance with it all up on the stage
and and they kind of make it a uh you
know a PT Barnum thing and when these
fish came up any Lake Erie walleye
fisherman will know if you hand them a
25 inch fish it should weigh between
four and five pounds and if you hand
them a 30 inch fish they will know
within six eight ounces what it should
weigh these two guys brought their fish
up and the tournament director who's
been doing this a long time
holds this fish up and to him it looks
like a five pound fish he puts it on the
scale and it weighs seven pounds
and because of all the accusations
behind the scenes associated with these
two guys
he became suspicious and kind of uh you
know inspected a little bit more closely
he felt something unusual in the belly
of this fish and then when they he got a
knife and opened it up these two massive
12-ounce lead balls roll out of its
belly so apparently allegedly and all
those qualifiers you know these guys had
been using lead weights to enhance the
weight of their catch
is this a felony
it's a felony uh felony fraud is what
the prosecutor tells me because like I
said it would have been Thirty or forty
thousand dollars that they would have
won Under you know these this pretext
that they you know cheated and uh bumped
up the weights but the bigger
controversy now is the fact that these
guys
supposedly won one of the major fall
tournaments last year and that was 150
Grand and they've won several other
tournaments and we think it's in the
neighborhood of uh with bonuses prize
money and sponsor money probably 400
Grand that they've won and the whole
time with these people you know saying
that they're cheating you know all this
going on in the background so there's a
lot more money here involved than people
think and the nature of the tournament
Dan is what makes it
so difficult to police so imagine a pro
golf tournament and the best golfers in
the world go out and it's just them and
their caddy and they play 18 and they
come in and they turn in their card and
there's nobody to say you know he didn't
get a 26 on the back you know he didn't
shoot a 29 on the front and that's
that's what happens is these guys go out
on the lake at the at first light and
they come back eight hours later
and you have to believe unless you
monitor it more closely or inspect it
you have to believe that they went out
and caught those fish
because there's a couple of things here
that uh I think some of the competitors
thought the fish looked a little too old
so maybe they brought the fish with him
also they weren't I think you donate the
fish to the local markets and they
weren't uh donating their fish to the
local markets that sound right here Matt
yes you're absolutely right those are
the two other red flags that have popped
up in the past because in a tournament
that was held near Toledo um in April
they won that tournament allegedly and
they went out and fished like four days
before the tournament intensely saying
they were Scouting For places and then
when they checked in their fish several
of the fishermen commented that their
fish looked old in other words the
tournament runs Friday and Saturday they
go out on a Tuesday and fish and catch a
couple big ones put them in a live well
on the boat turn the oxygen on and pump
and hope to keep them alive and then
when they go out and fish during the
tournament they mix those two big ones
in with the fish they actually caught to
try to bump up their catch but if you if
you were to donate your fish
to the local food pantry which every
other fisherman did in that Toledo
tournament except them the people that
are cleaning the fish would have said
hey wait a minute these are old we're
not giving this you know we're not
feeding foul fish to the folks down at
the soup kitchen so those were the other
red flags that they had caught fish
earlier put them in alive well and then
tried to mix those in with their catch
and also the fact that they didn't
donate their fish is a is a major red
flag because these guys are all
exceptional walleye fishermen they have
enough walleye in the freezer to feed
them and their you know their wife's
next husband but you know they for some
reason they kept their fish and nobody
else did we're talking to Matt Markey
Outdoors editor for the Toledo Blade any
reaction from these two uh Jacob Runyon
and Chase Kaminsky
Jacob brunion said I can't talk sorry
that's it and nothing from Kaminsky
that's the extent of their of their
reaction at this point and I tried to
find out yesterday neither one of them
has a legal representation as of this
point but I imagine once they're
formally charged in the Cuyahoga County
Court they will have uh attorneys you
know representing them and all but still
very early in that process and there's a
lot of questions about will they be sued
by these earlier tournaments by some of
their uh their sponsors who've given
them tens of thousands of dollars for
misrepresentation there's a Ohio
Division of Wildlife investigation for
violations that might have occurred out
on the lake because you can't take game
fish and manipulate them in any fashion
there's just a whole string of issues
other than the fact that um
the reputations obviously you know are
ruined if you cheat in golf in a pro
tournament you're done and these guys
have cheated in a professional walleye
tournament so they're done
I thought it was going to get ugly when
they started to weigh the fish and then
everybody started to gather and then all
of a sudden the tournament director cut
open a couple of those fish and you saw
those weights come out and I thought
These Guys these guys could get roughed
up here
they would have then except for uh the
tournament director is a full-time
police officer in Broadview Heights
which is a Cleveland suburb so he knew
how to at least try to maintain order
but there were a couple Cleveland police
officers on hand and he called them over
to basically escort these guys away from
the mob but you're absolutely right if
the police had not been there it would
have been much more than what we saw on
those videos it would have been there
would have been physical because a lot
of those guys in that crowd just
realized that all their suspicions were
true and that they had been cheated out
of tens of thousands of dollars in
previous tournaments where they might
have finished second or third of these
guys
and we see this with guys in sports and
other sports where they cheat too well
you know if if you put one weight in
there okay maybe it's not as obvious but
as you said this is what these guys do
they can feel a fish they can see the
size of the fish they know exactly and
these guys got too greedy to make sure
that they won this event or these other
events
I think so I think it worked in the past
and so they they got Brazen and they got
sloppy and what they did was was
actually very primitive you know using
the lead weights is probably the most
simple way to enhance the weight of a
fish but they went way over with these
lead balls and then they actually took
other fish and stripped the flesh off of
them and stuff that down there to try to
keep the lead from banging together and
um you know making it even more obvious
but they got they got sloppy and I think
it's like a lot of criminals after the
first 10 bank robberies go well then
maybe they get sloppy with their routine
these guys just got sloppy and Brazen
and you know a little bit too uh
aggressive in their approach and they're
lucky they got out of their life
Matt good to talk to you thanks for
joining us we'll be following this uh
whatever happens next
all right thank you Dan enjoyed it
Matt Markey Outdoors editor for the
Toledo Blade